the rules have changed we're dealing
with something new how the visions
artificial intelligence machine so it
doesn't count
no it's not like a person right
different rules for a nice guy
artificial things you can wield the
hammer you can keep the mind stone it's
safe with the vision and these days safe
is in short supply
but if you put the hammer in an elevator
would still go up my elevators not
worthy I'm gonna miss these little talks
of ours huh laughs you don't leave I
have no choice the mine stone is the
fourth of the Infinity stones to show up
in the last few years it's not a
coincidence someone has been playing an
intricate game has made pawns of us once
all these pieces are in position triple
Yahtzee you think you could find out
what's coming I do besides this one
there's nothing that can't be explained
that man has no regard for lawn
maintenance I'm gonna miss him though
and you're gonna miss me it's gonna be a
lot of manful tears I will miss you Tony
yeah well it's time for me to tap out if
I should take a page at a Barton's book
they'll pepper a farm hope nobody blows
it up a simple life you get there one
day
I don't know family stability guy wanted
all that went in the ice 75 years ago I
think someone else came out
all right
I'm home
you